Speaker 1: OK? Tucker Carlson is
going full anti-Semitic coddling
with a very special special about how dangerous
ninety one year old Holocaust survivor George
Soros is to the country and to the world. They're
not even pretending anymore. OK, Tucker Carlson
is. This is a Tucker Carlson original called
Hungary vs. Soros The Fight for Civilization.
This will be streaming today. The promo image,
which we have on screen, has an ominous looking
half face shot of George Soros, who is really they
are pointing and fingering public enemy number one
91 year old Holocaust survivor who donates to
liberal causes. George Soros Now, as many of you
know, many, many of you might not understand. What
does that mean? It's not. It's not, by definition,
anti-Semitic, and you're absolutely right. But
this is one of the oldest tropes now, which is the
conspiracy of wealthy Jewish individuals to take
control of society, often to make it communist
or socialist, which is crazy because George Soros
is like the ultimate capitalist. Look at how he's
made his money and very, very often if you start
following you, if you start following anti-vax,
if you start following shadow government, if
you store any of these conspiracy theories,
you follow them, follow the, follow them. You'll
find that the Jews are actually what underlies
this in in many different cases. So here's Tucker
Carlson, I guess, being interviewed by other Fox
people about Soros and the special.
Speaker 3: I mean, it's just a lie.
Anyone who says that is either
lying or doesn't know anything.
So I'm going to ask a super naive question,
because that's what I do. I'm like everybody here,
infuriated by the funding of the these progressive
Speaker 1: ideas, by these sorts,
Speaker 3: I guess, into open society or whatever
it's called. So I do what I look. I look him up
and I go, OK. He actually sounds like in the 80s,
I remember in the 80s how beloved he was because
he helped with the fall of the USSR. If my if my
memory is correct and I remember reading about it
National Review in the American Spectator and
I'm reading about his passing ago, you know,
his dad was in Siberia in a Siberian
prison. He escaped from Nazi Germany.
He helped with the fall of USSR. Does he? Is he
aware that his money is being used to destroy
America? Is this is something where he's not
paying attention to it because he's in his 90s?
I told you it was a naive question. Well, I
wouldn't just say America. I would say the West,
right? Western civilization.
Speaker 1: All of West George Soros,
at 91, is hell bent on the destruction
of Western civilization is his target.
Speaker 3: And I know a lot of people who know
Soros personally and some people who've done
business with him, every single person knows
him says this is one of the smartest, most
interesting people in the world. And I believe
that and I'm impressed by it. But his program
for the past 15 years, at least, has been to
make the societies he focuses on more dangerous,
dirtier, less democratic, more disorganized,
more at war with themselves, less cohesive.
In other words, it's a program of destruction
aimed at the West. No, I don't, you know,
I don't know what his motive is. I'm certainly not
going to guess. People are complicated. He clearly
is. But that's what that program is. So let's
not pretend it's a political program. It's not
increasing the number of murders in the country.
What is that? It's an attack on the country,
and that's what he's doing.
Speaker 1: And of course,
these claims are absurd. The idea that George
Soros is going out there saying, let's see how
we can get more murders going on. I mean, it's
quite literally the caricature of the clever,
rich Jewish guy behind the scenes figuring out
how to make everything. And it's like, how is that
even better for him? And I'm sure they have some
way. I'm sure they have some way to to explain
how increasing the number of murders is somehow
good for Soros. His long game, I mean, he's 91,
but he has some long game through which increasing
murders is going to be good for him. They're not
even pretending anymore, guys. And so that's the
special that Fox News is going to be running.